herzlich willkommen zur sternstunde
religion mein heutiger gast ist ein
jahrhundert zeuge pavia ben chorin wurde
in jerusalem geboren lange bevor der
staat israel gegründet wurde
drei kriegseinsätze in der israelischen
armee trägt nun zutiefst
sie brachten ihn dazu als rabbiner stets
den dialog zu suchen
die palästinensern mit juden mit
christen muslimen und auch mit atheisten
heute ist die band chorin rabbiner in
der jüdischen gemeinde in st gallen über
sein reiches leben über den dialog und
über die frage wie wir als menschen in
der heutigen zeit vertrauen bilden
können darüber spreche ich mit ihm in
der nächsten halben stunde
schön dass sie da sind rabbiner wenn
harry ich bedanke mich für die einladung
sie wurden 1936 in jerusalem geboren ja
was war das für ein leben als kind in
jerusalem anfang der 40er jahre
apfelkind war das sehr schön weil auch
sehr viel karo da waren dann kommt man
auch nicht in die schule gehen und das
sind die schönen seiten davon davon wird
nie gesprochen
aber sonst war so etwas sagt ich habe
viel mehr arabischen kindern gespielt
wurde auch mal von denen verhaut wenn
ich neun jahre alt waren kam nach hause
mit einer beule und mein vater fragte
mich was ist passiert
ja wir haben so schön gespielt und die
arabischen kinder haben uns verhaut da
war mein vater sehr empört nahm sein
schön borsalino hut und beschloss zum
motto des dorfes zu gehen an der tür
fragte mich was abgespielt also mitreden
in morgans wir haben so gespielt dass es
und ich war bei was habt ihr genau
gespielt wir haben ein kind genommen auf
unser schulter getragen und sind um
einem rondell rom gegangen und haben
geschehen begräbnis des mufti begriff
ist witzig daraufhin am main frage sein
boss an die latte und hat es wieder
aufgehängt mich eingeladen in seinem
arbeitszimmer zu kommen ich saß auf
seinen knien und hat mit wird solche
spiele darf man nicht spielen das
verletzt andere leute
das kann man nicht tun und ist nicht so
hoch dagegen haben sie die schelte nur
von ihrem vater bekommen wenn ich aus
ihrem erzählen so höre dann klingt das
für mich als sei eine große
selbstverständlichkeit von nähe zwischen
jüdischer bevölkerung und arabischer
bevölkerung ja ich war ja ich komme von
einem haus wo das dialog sehr echt da
war es waren immer wieder christen und
auch orthodoxe juden bei uns wir hatten
ein nachbar der einen rabbi einen
rassistischen rabi von tel aviv immer
bei sich hatte zum sommer und wir gingen
dort zum gottesdienst am freitagabend
die therapie vor einem nebenraum und hat
dort gebetet und die residiert die leute
kamen zum gebet haben immer reingeschaut
und der canto die weitergabe ist um es
zu koordinieren
also solche geschichten die ich dann in
wimbledon den physischen geschichten
lese habe ich selbst als kind diese
erfahrung gemacht und wurde auch erzogen
verschiedene richtungen des judentums
kennenzulernen und der erste mal wo ich
ein christbaum gesehen haben
weihnachtsbaum war ich sieben jahre alt
das waren bei kirchlichen bekannten die
nicht weit von uns wohnten und wie ich
16 jahre alt war habe ich sogar meine
mundharmonika angenommen und wir waren
im schwedischen instituts und haben
weihnachten und panogat zusammen
gefeiert und dem also in dieser
atmosphäre war das interreligiöse habe
ich gekannt und es muss auch sagen die
englischen soldaten in der mandatszeit
waren besonders nicht zu kindern also zu
allen kindern ohne unterschied ohne
unterschied zu kindern als solche für
durften schokolade bei ihnen kaufen in
der nach wie wenn es so der wagen kam wo
die soldaten sich sachen kaufen durften
durften wir uns auch eine schokolade
kaufen konnten mit denen auch sogar
reden
und dem besonders wenn ein speer war
konnte nicht raus und man konnte die
kinder nicht jemand zuhause halten
konnten wir dann immer von einem hof in
anderen springen hatten unsere stücke
konnten richtig soldaten stehen und da
waren echte panzer vor uns und wir
wussten auch immer wann die patronen
gehen damit wird sie nicht treffen
dass die eltern so ein vertrauen uns
sagen das verstehe ich bis heute nicht
aber wie lang kann man ein kind zu hause
halten ja und dem oder blei soldaten
dass ich mit einem freund gespielt habe
und war auch ein mädchen die wanne
tochter eines arzt der aus deutschland
kam und sie mit tränen
ihr habt immer kämpfe und ihr schickt
mir nicht genug verletzte ich habe mit
meinem spieltag nichts zu tun und ich in
meinen reform gesagt du sollst du stolz
sein
das wird nicht so viele verwundete haben
also sie sehen dass in solche
erinnerungen von einer zeit wo es nicht
immer so ruhig war aber ein kind sieht
das anders und wenn er auch tüchtige
eltern hatte meine mutter meine
leibliche motorrad eine zeichnerin und
hat auch die welt durch ihre positive
karikaturist ische form die welt
irgendwie gesehen und lassen sie mich
gerade bei ihren eltern bleiben ihr
vater starb der beiden elternteile
stammen aus deutschland ausmachen
ihr vater war religionswissenschaftler
religionsphilosoph hat sich dann später
sehr intensiv mit dem
christlich-jüdischen dialog befasst
beschwerden wurden sie mehr geprägt
durch den vater oder wie das klischee so
verlangt die jüdische musiker regnen
nein ich glaube im religiösen sinn wurde
ich mehr von meinem vater geprägt im
humanistischen sind der offene zugang zu
jedem menschen als menschen dass es sehr
stark von meiner mutter
und was mehr mit hebräischen sprache zu
tun hat ist wahrscheinlich mehr von
meiner stiefmutter also ich bin ein
moderner mensch der zwei meter hatte
meine stiefmutter wird ende februar 94
man kam auch als ein kind nach palästina
hat ihre älter sind du einen aus
schwitzen gekommen
wir hatten sie noch in israel besucht
und sind noch zurück nach deutschland
gegangen
unglaublich wir gehen wie gingen sie
dann als kind mit diesen ereignissen sie
waren bei der staatsgründung israels
waren sie zwölf jahre alt
in der zeit dazwischen ereignete sich
der zweite weltkrieg joshua ja was haben
sie davon als kind mitgekriegt
interessanterweise gab es zu dieser zeit
eine sehr gute die presse für kinder
zeitungen für kinder und die habe ich
genau gelesen und wir haben irgendwie
von diesen sachen bewusst
aber wissen sie die leute in israel es
hat gedauert bis sie gemerkt haben was
eigentlich in europa passiert und wir
hatten unsere eigene probleme im land
israel und im also wir wussten davon wir
haben ja auch immer wieder soldaten
gesehen ob es australische soldaten
waren in die show soll dann also aus
indien und natürlich den englischen und
die schottischen hat mir besonders gern
mit ihren rücken und dudelsack die waren
besonders attraktiv und dem also es eine
hochinteressante zu haben natürlich die
verschiedenen arabischen gruppen die es
auch gab und da gab es auf drei
baureihen zwischen juden und araber mal
geschossen oder steine geworfen tomaten
geworfen wenn man sind westermeyer ging
wurde man manchmal mit tomaten beworfen
das war nicht immer so angegeben die
präsenz von militärs in der region die
jetzt beschrieben haben hat das dazu
geführt dass sie selbst einfach in die
israelische armee eingetreten sind oder
war das kostete sie das überwindung
eines gottes kostet mich eine
überwindung ist
ein briefwechsel mit einem gesagt man
jemand nicht bereit ist zum krieg zu
gehen ein kriegsdienstverweigerer dies
verweigern
genau mit meinen dienst verweigern
nathan roshi von einem kibbuz und das
hat mich nicht überzeugt warum hat das
muss nicht überzeugt weil ich stand als
ehrengarde an der tafel in dem gymnasium
wo jedes jahr wieder ein oder zwei neuen
namen von schülern kann hier umgekommen
sind
und ich sage die eltern zu einer feier
kamen wo man die soldaten erwähnt hat
eine trauerfeier
ich sah so die eltern aber seit habe ich
eigentlich das recht nicht zu denen
besser im gefängnis zu setzen wenn man
erahnen schulkameraden im militär sind
das hat mich dazu gebracht dann ins
militär zu gehen
ich wollte eigentlich mit hunden zu tun
aber kam in den tank also in dem panzer
wäre ja um ich hab das panzer wäre sehr
gern weil im panzer sind genug plätze
dafür bücher mitzunehmen und das hat mir
nein kriegen und er wird jetzt immer
wieder geholfen
sie haben in mehreren interviews schon
bereits erwähnt dass sie ganz spezifisch
erlebnisse hatten in ihren
kriegseinsätzen die sie dann letztlich
auch dazu gebracht haben diese dialog
allzu einzunehmen was war ja ich war in
einen bekriegen
das war im sinai in einem ob das heißt
angela das ist ein große basis der
ägypter und wir haben das gestürmt und
da kam plötzlich so daten zu mir und
sagten hier ist ein offizier gelegt im
bunker und der möchtegern nebenan
treffen und niemand konnte arabisch oder
englisch und da bin ich hingegangen und
er lag da habe ich gesagt am very sorry
to see und die situation
das schaute mich so andererseits wissen
sie es hätte auch umgekehrt sein können
sie liegen können und ich würde stehen
ja absolut bereit sie haben vollkommen
recht dann hatte meine vorgestellt hat
jemand gefragt ob sie wirklich jeden
angela sein wollen und die zeit wo wir
uns jetzt treffen
ja ich werde sie mich so fragen nein
aber ich und so hat jemand sie gefragt
nein sagt es sehen sie und zu erleben
wird von politikern geleitet gemalt die
gar nicht mal miteinander sprechen und
schauen sie was die situation ist das
hat mich sehr geprägt das wird das eine
und das zweite war bevor wir eine andere
position gestürmt haben sind wir auf
einem hügel rauf und ich sah plötzlich
zwei hände mit dem ehering hat man
gedacht mein liebes bisschen auf mich
wartet familie zu hause und ich sehe
dass auf dem wurden nur noch die hände
da sind mit dem er ihn warten auch
mehrere leute die wissen es noch nicht
ich weiß es schon und am ende was hab
ich gelernt man sitzt miteinander man
spricht also wenn einer mehr tote hat
und der andere weniger wels-land der
sieger es kommen leute auf beiden seiten
man spricht dann immer miteinander die
frage ist haben sie nicht manchmal zu
viel freiheit als wir wirklich wollen
als menschen sagten sie mir die antwort
ihren nachnamen bedeutet glaube ich so
gut der freiheit der name der ihr vater
gewählt gewählt hat ja genau
und dieser auch so kommt auch in büchern
dass man zu ostern zu pessach zum psa
haben liest heißt haggada da ist es
dieses jahr sind wir knechte nächstes
jahr also entweder hoher insel in der
freiheit mein vater nahm das pseudonym
und es wurde auch dann unser
familienname
ich glaube wir müssen lernen wie mit
freiheit umzugehen
ich glaub gratis die monotheistischen
religion wenn wir sie nicht so eng
fundamentalistisch nehmen sondern ihm
ermöglichen zu sehen wie sich historisch
entwickelt haben
sie können den menschen wären wie mit
freiheit umzugehen
ich weiß dass viele kriege im namen der
religion geführt worden sind aber auch
sehr viel der ganz dem wunsch und traum
des friedens geht zurück zu den
jüdischen propheten im der hebräischen
bibel inter nach also diese vision von
einer welt fliehen das dann im
christentum und auch in dem islam im
fürstentum als kommen des messias oder
islam ja mal den und der tag danach
auferstehung die auferstehung genau also
diese forschung sind da hat nur sind oft
leute so an die fundamente gebunden dass
sie das nicht als quellen benutzen wo
sie dann weiter auch von sich entwickeln
ich glaube gott hat uns genug von luft
gegeben um auch die eigene religion die
immer und der offenbarung kommt aber sie
geht durch den zieht es menschen die
subjektivität des menschen
und wenn ich bereit bin durch
wissenschaftlichen arbeiten zu geben wo
die subjektivität ist kann ich auch zur
hauptsache kommen und schließlich
unendlich glaube ich sind wir alle co
partner des schöpfers nicht nur wir
brauchen gott gott braucht auch uns
dafür sind hier auf dieser erde was man
jetzt die neuen erden finden wird was
dort e10 ist wissen sie ich habe genug
probleme bezogen
sie verstehen sich als liberaler
rabbiner sie plädieren für ein liberales
julia kuhn sagen aber das liberale
judentum ist in israel beispielsweise
nicht anerkannt was ich tat nicht
anerkannt was was bedeutet das für sie
konkret hilfen sie in israel nicht als
rabin all ihren lehrern darf ich doch
die freiheit sprechen aber ich kann
keine hochzeiten führen die dann vom
staat anerkannt sind auf den friedhof
kann ich nicht aktiv mitmachen nur wenn
das begräbnis zu ende ist und im terra
biener ist keine der liberale labine
wird nicht als autorität angesehen vom
staat ist denn das was für ihn gelten
als nicht möglich sich zu schließen sind
es zb in einen juden und nichtjuden es
gibt keine zivile er nicht sehen also
die die zivil heiraten wollen gehen nach
zypern oder gehen nach europa gekommen
in der schweiz sind sie denn befugte
jetzt viele in der schweiz eine ehe zu
schließen
ja aber der staat anerkennt nur die em
die vom die zivilehe ja die zeremonie
als solche ist nicht erkannt in england
ist es umgekehrt in england kann man
oder zivil oder religiös heiraten sind
beide vom staat anerkannt eine frage
also eine schlüsselfrage die sich in
allen religionsgemeinschaften stellt und
sozusagen die der prüfstein der
liberalität ist ist auch die frage
welche position frauen einnehmen nicht
nur im alltag und in der gesellschaft
sondern auch bei der frage welche
religiösen ämter übernehmen diesen
dieser ihre position darf es aus ihrer
sicht rabbinerinnen geben nicht nur darf
ich habe sogar ein am rabbinerseminar
gelehrt in den letzten sechs jahren in
berlin am abraham geiger kolleg wo wir
rabbiner unserer wienerinnen gelehrt
haben und definiert haben und auch er
kanton und kantor innen also ich gehöre
da ganz klar zu einer liberalen position
wo die gleichberechtigt ist nicht nur
weil es mir angenehmer ist es heißt
schon im gang ist im ersten kapitel dass
gott mann und frau sie geschaffen hat
also sagt nieke war männlich ein mann
und ein weib also eine frau und da dazu
geht es zurück aber wie ich ihn vor hin
sagt
religion ist auch immer beeinflusst von
zeit und raum in der sie sich entwickelt
und der die spannung zwischen männer und
frauen ist eine lange geschichte in der
geschichte der menschheit und das
überwinden wir sind immer noch im
prozess der aufklärung und wissen sie
was für mich interessant ist dass sogar
männer und vorhanden in ihrer 30 et
strecke viel konservativer sind als ich
das ist ein phänomen das ist ein
phänomen
ich saß mit einer gruppe von leuten und
das sagt hat mir jemand gesagt haben
sind sie meinen sie es uns wie behalte
ich bin viel lieber als sich das sind
sie verheiratet ja habt ihr ein
bankkonto ja wer darf es unterschreiben
natürlich nur ich aber meine frau weiß
sie kann alles bekommen was sie will
haben sie die antwort ja das ist so tief
in und zur seele das und diese spannung
kommt auch natürlich in der bibel vor
und erst post biblisch wird das liberale
und jetzt in den letzten 200 jahren sind
wir wirklich in einem prozess von einer
revolution im judentum
wenn ich sage judentum nicht im engen
religiösen sinn sondern als eine
zivilisation in der region eine sehr
wichtige rolle hat aber nicht die letzte
jude ist ist ein gläubiger jude weil wir
wenig leben will muss ein teil der
tradition halten auch wenn es für ihn
nur eine kultur ist stichwort kultur
lassen sie uns noch einen schritt weiter
in ihrer biografie gehen ja zwischen
2009 und 2015 haben sie als rabbiner in
berlin amtiert ja wie wichtig war es
ihnen dass sie zurück zu ihren deutschen
wurzeln gehen konnten oder in dem land
als rabbiner wirken konnten aus dem
vater oder ihre eltern vertrieben wurden
das ist eine gute frage die sie mir
stellen
ich glaube sicherlich hat es mich
innerlich irgendwie beruhigt
und war sogar einnehmen
wie soll ich sagen eine bestimmte
befriedigung da wo ich auch merck
tatsächlich vielleicht mein vater ein
bisschen nach haben sie müssen wissen
ich habe deutsch eigentlich nie gelernt
ich wurde zweisprachig erzogen und so
habe ich die deutsche sprache aber warum
also wie ich immer so gerne sage sie ist
mehr als verständlich aber sie ist nicht
immer ganz druckreif
und plötzlich in diesem milieu obwohl es
berlin war und nicht münchen
das hat mich innerlich in die werden in
neue innere balance gebracht weil in
israel
ich bin sehr von israel geprägt aber das
deutsche element in mir das
deutsch-jüdische einem band ist vielmehr
dann zum ausdruck gekommen durch die 13
jahre in zürich und dann sechs jahre in
bälde als es waren in zürich bei der
woche sind sie nach berlin und jetzt
installiert sind
sie sind seit über 50 jahren verheiratet
sie haben wunderbar ja sie haben zwei
söhne und fünf enkel ja was haben sie
denen als teil der deutschen kultur
mitgegeben aus der deutschen kultur wir
haben sie nichts bekommen weil meine
frau kommt aus philadelphia aus amerika
und da haben sie mehr die amerikanische
kultur mitbekommen wir sprechen auch
sehr viel englisch zu hause das deutsch
ist mehr mit mir geblieben und ihm und
söhne und schwiegertöchter sprechen kein
deutsch also und wohlleben ihre kinder
und enkel in israel ein ende ältere sohn
in tel aviv und der junge reden haifa
der ältere sohn ist ein rechtsanwalt und
ist ein atheist der sich sehr gut im
judentum sich auskennt und wände in
gerichthof zu arbeitet und sieht dass
der richter ein käppchen anhat dann
zitierte mehr quellen schreibt werden
elektroherde ohne kapsel ist dann
benutzern anders wie kommen sie denn als
vater und rabbiner damit zurecht dass
einer ihrer söhne atheist ist
ich glaube das ist sein gutes recht die
frage ist wie kommt er damit
es ist uns klar dass er als eltern sehr
starke figuren sind weil wir beide sehr
im öffentlichen leben sehr aktiv sind
meine frau hat abgelehnt und meine frau
ist die tochter eines rabbiners sie ist
die schwester eines rabbiners sie ist
die mutter eines orbiters und sie ist
die frau eines rabbiners also meine
kollegen haben ziemlich angst wo man
kann das eigentlich nicht noch steigern
weil alles nicht steigen
schauen sie dass eltern gerne sehen dass
die kinder irgendwie die tradition
weiterführen während dieselben werte das
ja das haben wir aber unser sohn ist
bewusst atheist persönlich liebe ich
sehr hatte essen weil die wirklich
mitbringen die anderen die so sicher
sind und an direkten linie haben zu gott
da beneide ich sie ein bisschen das kann
ich von mir nicht behaupten
ich kann von mir nur behaupten dass ich
das starke gefühl haben ein kontakt sei
mit dem schöpfer und ich suche immer
wieder ein gleichgewicht zu stellen
zwischen schöpfer schöpfung und
erschaffen
in diesen zwei enkel gesagt man in
diesem dreieck diesem dreieck versuche
ich zu leben und ich glaube auch sehr an
das zyklus hafte im leben und auch nach
dem leben als auch seen wanderung ja
weniger an der auferstehung und mehr
seen wanderung
das ist schon meine subjektive form aber
ich anerkenne dass andere ihre
subjektivität haben
ich suche auch nicht die objektivität
ich glaube das ist eine gefährliche
westliche illusion
sie glauben nicht alle angehen der griff
der objektiven wahrheit auch nicht in
der objektive wahrheit sehen sind das
hört sich sehr schön an kann ich
überhaupt objektiv sein weil wenn ich
schon ein verhältnis zu der materie habe
ist schon eine subjektive
auch in der naturwissenschaft der
naturwissenschaftler etwas untersucht
hängt so an seine untersuchung weil er
ein gefühl zu dieser materie hat und um
enden sich noch immer wieder theorien
das ist doch das schöne ich stark prägt
sie jetzt diese haltung in dialog
situationen ich selbst komme auch aus
dem interreligiösen dialog sehr 25
jahren und ich mache oft die erfahrung
dass im islamischen dialog der dialog so
lange gut geht bis dann die
gretchenfrage nach dem verhältnis zum
staat israel auftaucht und dann ist der
dialog quasi am ende aber eigentlich
möchte man ihm jedoch weiterführen
welchen ratschlag welchen impuls können
sie geben dass dieses politische thema
nicht sozusagen zum zentrum des dialoges
zwischen muslimen und juden und auch
inzwischen mit kristen wird
ich war jetzt vor kurzem in ungarn war
eingeladen von haus aufwandes ein
projekt in berlin wo sie nagen kirche
und musste unter einem dach sind und die
wolken etwas mehr hören wie dieses
projekt angefangen hat und das war s so
schön mal mit moslems zusammen zu sein
die über israel kaum gesprochen haben
also dass man kann auch diese erfahrung
machen belastet denn das thema ist sie
persönlich derart dass sie froh sind
dass muslime ist nicht aufgreifen ist es
nicht auch ein bisschen so ein bisschen
ein eiertanz den man nach dass man sagt
man umschifft sozusagen die heiklen
klippen auf man weiß sie sind da nein
ich glaube es ist sehr wichtig darüber
zu sprechen
die frage ist wie weit die muslimische
seite die wissenschaftliche kritische
form historische form bereit ist
aufzunehmen
und da wird manchmal probleme mit
rabbiner hinsichtlich der islamischen
theologie oder hinsichtlich der
islamischen theologie hinsichtlich der
jüdischen theologie hinsicht der
christlichen theologie was jesus machte
und was wir von ihm behauptet es nicht
immer dasselbe und ich glaube das stimmt
für alle drei religionen
jetzt ist die frage wie weit projizieren
wir ich glaube wir ziehen alle bin ich
bereit das zuzugeben ich bin dabei
sofort bereit zuzugeben was mich in
dialog mir wichtig ist sind zwei sachen
halte mein duft der optik sehr gut für
gold für die schweiz figuren sieht es
der angler wirklich der andere wie
arbeitet sein kopf wie denkt was ist wir
sind in werte die so wichtig sind und
ich hoffe dass ich ihn zu ernst nehme
wie ich lasse mich ernst nimmt dass wir
das erste also zum beispiel wie schmidt
ein moslemischen imam saß aus marokko
und er mir erklären wollten dass die
ersten araber die kann annika waren und
dass die im heiligen land noch vor die
juden dort waren so wie sie jetzt ein
bisschen lächeln habe ich auch gelernt
und die andere leute dieses um das
werden darf
jetzt werden wir ein zusammenstoß haben
gesagt dass eine interessante
interpretation der geschichte
warum ist das ihn so wichtig plötzlich
die kanal meter als araber darzustellen
das ist doch eigentlich im siebten
jahrhundert und etwas gut da kann man
bestimmte emotionen
lesen sie im dialog muss man auch
manchmal lernen zu schweigen und so zu
hören
die höchste stufe des diallo ist für
mich wenn man miteinander auch über
seine eigenen schwächen sprechen kann
und da habe ich einen christlichen
freund ein jesuiten und mit dem komm ich
soweit und wenn der eine messe leitet
kann ich mit beeten wäre das ihr
ratschlag an die jüngere generation also
meine generation aber auch schon bereits
die nächste generation öfter mal zu
schweigen zuzuhören
ich glaube das ist wichtig in jede
partnerschaft das hat nicht nur mit
religion zu tun
aber je mehr diese stille da ist durch
den andern dann kann auch die
inspiration kommen
ob sie göttlich ist oder nur von mir
lassen wir das offen ein bisschen
mysterium darf doch noch da sein
ein wunderbares schlusswort ganz ganz
herzlichen dank herr rabbiner wenn
chorin für dieses gespräch
danke vor zwei wochen verstarb in zürich
82 jährig allem fällt als katholischer
priester in afrika wurde er zu einem der
bedeutendsten vermittler zwischen
afrikanischen und europäischen
lebenswelten und eine prägende figur für
das engagement der schweiz auf dem
afrikanischen kontinent
aus anlass seines todes zeigen wir ihnen
nun den film aus dem jahr 2014 alle im
feld priester journalist und freigeist
[Musik]